hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
battle royale has had a remarkable
update today which changes many things
so let's quickly break them down this is
nine new things in update 1.8 the first
thing of note is the timed halloween'
event which runs until November the 4th
that's 9 days in total if you're an
overwatch fan you'll already understand
these events in this shot window new
cosmetic items can be purchased which
will no longer be available after
November the 4th it's basically for our
internal narcissism and if you are
without the bass game then you'll
struggle to get the be bucks needed for
purchase unless you use real money of
course and don't be too hard on the devs
it's a free-to-play title so they need
to make money some ways the time to
vanity items include two fancy dress
options the ghoul trooper and the skull
trooper and a Reaper style side instead
of the trusty pickaxe you always take
with you I have to admit that thing
looks damn good the Reaper in particular
is a daily cosmetic item probably trying
to flush you into buying quickly we'll
see if it's still there tomorrow but at
present it will change every 24 hours
the new locker menu will be the hub for
character customization everything we
buy should be completely cosmetic so we
all remain on an even playing field so
the ones who have mom and dad's credit
card won't be off a powered compared to
someone who doesn't have any cash once
again this is following the standard set
by overwatch even the banners we hold
can be customized at the moment a pink
frilly glider is for sale making me want
to throw away my umbrella and there's
also a red renegade suit if that's your
bag these purchasing balls look to be
changing every single day XP has now
been added to the game so you can level
up to your heart's content and show your
dedication and skills to help with that
the daily challenges are here to keep
you committed to the cause today it's
killing people
as an extension to that the leaderboard
system has been implemented you are
placed in a division of fifty people and
your total wins and top place finishes
dictate who will be the winner of that
league the weekly reset for this
activity will be Wednesdays the game
will be cut in two seasons with unique
rewards for active players banner flares
will be added from level 2 onward and 2
unique banners will be handed out at
level 10 and level 25 remember to do
those daily challenges to level up
faster let's quickly go back to the
seasonal event of Halloween and the
rocket launcher which will be around for
9 days in-game a pumpkin infused rocket
launcher which I didn't find on my
troubles so sadly this is the only
footage I could capture but it's the
sound which really adds to this effect
so I'll shut my face and let you listen
a new consumable with a ridiculous name
slurp juice makes its entrance this
concoction gives you 25 health and 25
shield button like specific health and
shield potions the slurp juice
introduces a regeneration mechanic once
you drink for the next 25 seconds you
will receive one health and one shield
every single second for the science of
this I jumped off a cliff to test this
one out this one could be brilliant when
running into certain confrontation and
as the best strategy to use slurp juice
is discovered I'll be sure to update you
all as you already know voice chat is
imperative to group games and now voice
chat is included without the need for
party chat so when joining randoms you
can converse without the rigmarole of
finding a player's username or adding a
random person to your friends list very
useful a great quality of life update
introduced in 1.8 is the ability to
automatically pick up ammo resources and
traps that's right the days of
accidentally picking up unwanted weapons
are gone but we still need to press the
correct button to pick up potions and
consumables so that's where we are with
update 1.8 ha ps4 in a nutshell the only
thing I really didn't speak about is the
weapon balancing which I haven't
witnessed enough of to give adequate
feedback just yet oh there is actually
one more thing a new controller setup is
available on console which is designed
to keep your thumbs on the sticks longer
give it a go if you have chance to let
me know your thoughts anyway what do you
think of the changes and the inclusion
of cosmetic items I'd love to know your
opinions and what I really want to know
is will you spend real money in battle
royale it's a tough choice isn't it
anyway I imagine from PlayStation
grenade it's been a pleasure for more on
for tonight's battle royale please give
us a subscribe I'll see you next time
you